if you are trying to lose weight you
will want to pay attention to some new
research offering advice to the best
times of the day to eat the study finds
only eating between 7 a.m and 3 p.m help
participants lose weight more than those
eating during a 12-hour window it was
published in gemma internal medicine
good housekeeping deputy nutrition
director and registered dietitian
stephanie sassos is here to discuss the
study and how you can apply it to your
life good morning good morning thank you
for having me okay so this is quite the
eye-catching headline yes
what did this study actually find yeah
so it looked about 90 participants ended
up being about 60 when all was said and
done that completed it and there were
two separate groups like you mentioned
the first group was the control group
they ate about 12 hours or more a day
and they had to restrict about 500
calories less than normal and the second
group was these early um eaters where
they were eating from 7 a.m to 3 p.m
same thing they also had to restrict
about 500 calories a day and we found
both groups lost weight but there was
more weight loss in that early eating
group and the reason why these
researchers did this you know time
restricted eating or intermittent
fasting it's not new right right but
this early window there are certain
circadian rhythms in metabolism think
things like insulin sensitivity and the
thermic effect of food that are
optimized earlier in the day okay did
the researchers mention that from 3 pm
on when you're not eating people do a
lot of like hanging out socializing
watching tv i mean like happy hour
that's the crappiness level that happens
you know like you put money in the
square jar i think for that period right
totally well that's the bottom line
right is is it sustainable and can you
stick with it right you basically say
goodbye to any social life and i think
in the summer we're all going to
barbecues most of them start at two or
three are you gonna be stuffing
hamburgers in your face at 259. like
it's not totally sustainable right um
but people actually did see an
improvement in mood which was
interesting in the 14 weeks and look
you're losing weight you're feeling good
but when it comes down to maintaining it
most of these people said it wouldn't
really be something that would be
effective in the long term and only
eight people said they could stick to
the 7 a.m to 3 p.m window which is
really interesting right because their
parents eating with their kids there are
shift workers who work overnight i
thought it was so interesting you
pointed out the increased mood
effects and also a reduction in blood
pressure why would that be yeah so with
blood pressure we know as your weight
increases your blood pressure increases
as well and even losing as much as 10
pounds can really make considerable
differences in your blood pressure um so
there definitely is incentive with that
but weight is not the ultimate
determinant of health and i really want
to stress that right there are so many
other things like your cholesterol your
blood sugar levels that really impact
our health in the long term and think
about 7 a.m to 3 p.m are you eating junk
food the whole time or are you eating
nutritious wholesome foods right that's
really what it boils down to in terms of
longevity how much of this is just about
following a system any system over a
prolonged period of time i think
intermittent fasting is so um
attractive to so many people because
it's just start eating at this time and
stop eating at this time you're not
tracking calories you're not counting
macros right but maybe you can take the
research and the findings from the study
and implement certain things into your
own life right so maybe you say okay at
8 p.m i'm going to stop eating for the
rest of the night and cut out that late
night snacking right or i'm not going to
eat overnight that's a big thing back
when i was in private practice a lot of
people eat in the middle of the night
it's a huge issue
don't people sleep in the middle
they go to bed and they wake up and wake
up for a snack and then they go back
like you've never i sleep right through
okay all right i think you know look i i
have a young baby so i'm up in the
middle of the night right and so
scenario you're tempted to maybe grab
something from the fridge
it's very very common but it really is
important to try and keep that overnight
fast because that's going to help you
sleep better improve your mood your
weight all the above okay so when it
comes to these time restricting diets or
eating schedules um how do you do it in
a healthy way yeah so i think if you
look at your particular lifestyle your
job for example right you guys are
probably waking up super early so maybe
this winter could work for you but
someone who's at a normal nine to five
maybe you put something like 12 to 8 or
10 to 6 maybe a better window um and
ultimately like i said it's about the
quality of the foods you're eating i
can't stress that enough right
making sure that you're filling that
window with nutritious wholesome foods
to help you prevent chronic disease and
really calories are not just a calorie
the quality of those calories matters
and you've got to think about what it's
doing to the earth right nate that's
true you heard my top of the table all
right stephanie deputy uh director of
nutrition at good housekeeping thank you
very much thank you guys